a man who came to me in the mid 90s
um who had been on an interagency deep
Black Project group he says he says I
was on a committee in 1974.
so almost 50 years ago where we could
push a button the skies would be filled
with all kinds of these man-made UFOs
they could attack or do certain actions
wow and it and it would be you know it
would create such fear and he said
because the president and the Congress
don't know we have these assets they
would be stampeded into all kinds of
responses and so would the public and
the Press so when he and if he was the
only man I had met with who had been in
a top secret operation like that I would
have discounted it but I've met many of
them who knew about this agenda and so
that is my biggest concern is that if
the if the public and the media aren't
aware of all this and the president and
the National Security Council are and
most of the Congress virtually all of
them then they could all be deceived in
this kind of operation so I think that's
my biggest concern and when I was on I
was on a four-week trip and so recently
and all this nonsense broke
you were and I were texting back and
forth and I said Yep this is what we
predicted most people who look at my
materials from the 90s went wow you know
Dr Greer was saying that this is the
kind of Direction they're going to move
in in the future so my concern is that
as we move forward with a dispositive
disclosure on this and now the Congress
has got behind a pathway to do that that
they could actually push that button
um and and that's a very big concern of
mine
it sounds like there's a sector of
people that are uninformed and so a lot
of that everybody yeah so what are the
questions that you get when you do these
presidential briefings and everybody at
the top of their top of their group what
what what kind of questions are they
asking you like the ones you're asking
they don't know anything I mean
interestingly I mean it was I remember
meeting years ago back in the early
2000s with the member of the Senate
intelligence committee who ironically
was from the state of Nevada
which is where Area 51 Ellis Air Force
Base is and uh it's very funny how that
meeting happened I was put on a one of
those little golf courts golf carts at
McCarran airport in Las Vegas and I was
we were I was moved in clandestinely to
what looked like a Janitor's Closet and
it ended up being a place where VIPs
could meet and the senator and his chief
of staff were in there
and we have this very extensive meeting
about this and you know he says look you
know this is my home state I'm on the
Senate intelligence committee I have a
I've heard these things but I have never
been briefed on it or read into it so
now you take that experience that I've
had here
and all over the world with senior
government officials and they're really
I feel very compassionate for them
because everyone thinks oh you're the
president you're this General you're
this Cabinet member most of them don't
know anything the ones who have known
things
like vice president Cheney he was on
this Cobra deep black committee since
70s and 80s
um way back
and they're embedded in various places
in government but their job is to
actually turn to their colleagues let's
say you're a corrupt Senator or
congressman who knows about this because
you're part of a club it's like doctors
believe each other lawyers believe each
other NASCAR racers
um
but here's what happens they turn to
their peerage let's call it and say oh
none of this is true if it were true I
would know about it and I you know I've
been involved in all kinds of projects
and this is what they're trained to do
there's actually a facility on my way
out to Charlottesville Virginia where
Thomas Jefferson's house is you go by a
town called Culpepper Virginia and Out
in the Country there there's a place
simply called the farm and this is where
they take people to learn how to very
professionally and convincingly lie
deceive they could pass polygraphs but I
know people who've gone through the farm
and um it's a very effective training
program but diabolical in many ways not
for normal let's call it spycraft but
for folks doing this where they're
actually involved in a criminal and
illegal operation that nobody is
allowing the key people now remember in
the Constitution
if you do things that you know the
reason I'm saying these programs are
unconstitutional and and criminal is
that I can prove and afford a law from
all the people I briefed
that and it's not just our country
United Kingdom Australia Canada that if
you're at that level
let's say you're the head of the defense
intelligence agency Danica which is like
the CIA for the for the military it's
the CIA civilian defense intelligence
agency is for the whole military and I
have briefed the director the head guy
at the DIA
he wasn't given that he told where the
washroom was on this issue and so I was
actually brought in to brief him at his
conference room and he went over this is
really kind of comical he went over to
his bookshelf
and he grabs a little uh like you get at
a choice or a little E.T doll he says
this is all I've ever gotten for my
inquiries through channels at the
defense intelligence agency someone just
was making fun of him
so I'm going yes I'm not surprised
that's happened because I prior to you
briefed all these other senior officials
who have been also denied access when in
93 when I met with the director of the
CIA and learned that he and the
president had been denied access that's
when I knew we were in big trouble so if
they don't know anything and if they're
not part of this deep black
covert group are they so bad is the
government so bad are they a different
level of it maybe like a just a one step
below can we trust the government oh
well I don't I think even the founding
fathers who say you never just trust the
government that's why we're supposed to
have the fourth estate the media and the
public and elections but the problem is
is if that if you can't blame people for
what they don't know or don't even know
the questions to ask so getting back to
your point
many of the things that people when I
meet with these sort of folks that what
they're asking is to be honest with you
they know less than someone who has
looked at the documentary unacknowledged
but you can still see for free on Amazon
Prime or Hulu or 2B or whatever because
they're so busy with a million other
pressing issues
that this issue until it gets put on
their radar and again and the people
someone says you need to take a look at
this yeah but these people are very busy
I mean you know I mean it's it's very
hard to get them to focus on something
that has been deliberately relegated to
the realm of Coupes and conspiracy
theory it's gonna rise to the top of the
rise of the top of the to-do list though
with everything that's been going on
lately it seems it is it's beginning to
get there and uh now the problem is
about a year ago I'll say this I need to
be careful what I'm saying here in
February of 2022 I was contacted by an
extremely senior person who had been
tasked with looking into this
and this was someone who should have had
an all-access pass on everything black
budget and classified he's at that level
and he said uh you know I know that
we're being deceived and now we now
realize that they have been chasing
their tails for a couple years
um since the first bill was passed
mandating that the government the
Pentagon report to Congress on this but
they've never gotten anything meaningful
so this guy turned to me he says can you
help us I said oh yeah what do you want
so we're in this secure facility
um
you know a skiff is a secure compartment
of information facility
classified and you give up your cell
phone and it's electronically all this
stuff
um and I gave him everything so I'm
still what I'm doing right now
I have handed off about a four or five
terabyte hard drive that is a massive
intelligence collection that we have and
I in it I named every facility every
corporation where the gates are where
the deep underground bases are Etc
and based on that in the last year
they've been able to hit Pay Dirt
they've been able to get in
uh but it's dangerous I mean it's it's
very dangerous I mean you know you know
we got put on the watch
group list which is the kill list were
the Men in Black just about to show up
are the Men in Black real
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen